la conférence de munich en allemagne
une conférence sur la sécurité mondiale
2e journée dont qui s'achève et les
leaders du monde politique qui s'y
retrouvent jusqu'à demain le thème de
cette 56e édition c'est la perte
d'influencé progressive de l'occident
une thématique sur laquelle a longuement
parlé emmanuel macron le président
français qui a plaidé en faveur d'une
défense européenne et d'un dialogue
notamment avec la russie qui l'a accusé
tout de même de vouloir déstabiliser les
démocraties occidentales
côté russe sergueï lavrov a réagi
notamment sur la situation syrienne
on va retrouver sur place notre envoyé
spécial bassem shelly deuxième journée
de cette conférence sécurité de munich
emmanuel macron sergueï lavrov tous deux
ont profité de cette tribune ou proposée
par la conférence pour étayer leurs
propos concernant la politique
internationale et pour exposer la vision
de la politique de leur pays sergueï
lavrov a commencé son discours en
parlant d'une barbarisation des
relations internationales il a déclaré
qu'il fallait arrêter de parler de la
menace russe mais qu'il fallait
travailler conjointement et se
concentrer sur ce qui nous lie est il a
parlé également de la stabilisation de
la région qui était nécessaire pour
mener à bien toutes les politiques
conjointe
il a également parlé de coopération et
globales qui était nécessaire pour
pouvoir régler les conflits qui siègent
au sein de la région
il a également parlé sur les différents
sujets tels que l'iran tels que la syrie
la libye ou encore le conflit israélo
palestinien une question a été posée à
sergueï lavrov concernant les relations
entre la russie et la turquie il s'est
montré rassurant en disant que même
s'ils ne partageait pas les mêmes points
de vue
la turquie et la russie restaient des
partenaires je vous propose d'écouter
sergueï lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe avec la turquie nous
avons de très bonnes relations
on ne peut pas être d'accord sur tout je
pense pas que deux pays peuvent avoir
à un accord parfait sur tous les points
sinon ça ressemble un peu à une pression
qui a été organisée de la russie avec la
turquie et l'iran les trois pays alors
qu'ils ont des divergences dans leurs
objectifs mais je vais pas entrer dans
les détails vous comprenez très bien ce
que je veux dire mais en tout cas nous
avons été unis sur la volonté de
participer de aidez-le à la syrie à se
reconstruire à l'état vous leur entendu
sergueï lavrov se voulait rassurant
quant aux relations entre la turquie et
puis la russie saga lavrov est même
revenu sur la position russie a dit que
la russie était prête à coopérer sur
l'agenda international juste avant un
sergueï lavrov c'était emmanuel macron
qui a profité de cette tribune proposé
par la conférence pour exposer sa vision
de l'europe et de la défense il a parlé
d'un affaiblissement de l'occident il a
dit que les pays européens devaient
coopérer davantage entre eux et
d'injecter beaucoup plus d'argent dans
l'union européenne pour pallier à
l'absence et surtout pas lié au retard
pris face à la chine
et puis face aux états unis emmanuel
macron a adressé un mot concernant la
russie il a parlé d'une politique de
déstabilisation menées par la russie par
des acteurs privés et publics
eurus bien sûr il a dit que la porte
était ouverte pour la russie qu'il
fallait coopérer davantage avec la
russie qui est un partenaire clef qu'il
ne fallait pas isolé a réussi mais
travailler avec la russie voilà en gros
ce qu'on pouvait retenir de cette
deuxième journée de conférences de
qualité de munich et bien sûr nous
continuerons de suivre cette conférence
troisième journée de conférence qui
s'annonce aussi chargé sur des dossiers
tels que la syrie la libye la défense ou
encore la coopération internationale